foreign
this is the first time Valerie's been
back to the prison where the Russians
took him
up
the Larry is a successful businessman
and was arrested when he resisted after
soldiers stole his trucks from his
Factory but what the Russians didn't
know was their crimes were recorded on
CCTV as they looted his office and drove
away his Vehicles he shows me the images
on his phone
14th of March yeah
each one is dated It All Happened
shortly after they invaded Kirsten City
yeah smashed up the computers
on the walls of the prison graffiti
reads zelenski we are coming
Valeri considers himself lucky as other
inmates were tortured far worse
foreign
[Music]
foreign
the pain of the Russian occupation is
everywhere this is a city still coming
to terms and dealing with a collective
trauma
there are still people out celebrating
but much of the Euphoria has given way
to something else and that is the
Practical reality of surviving in a city
where everything is in short supply now
when the Russians left they destroyed
much of the infrastructure and the local
authorities here are saying that this
place is now facing a humanitarian
catastrophe
every day the cues for water get longer
a miserable weight in the biting cold
power two is hard to come by people
crowd around a generator to charge their
phones and torches
amongst them is Lisa who's been waiting
here for the last three hours it's
becoming part of her daily routine but
she's apprehensive
foreign
you can of course still feel the
intoxicating atmosphere of liberation
but people are weary and they're fearful
of what comes next Alex Rossi Sky News
Quezon City